okay so today we're starting modern
philosophy and we're not going to get a
lot of this during the semester because
I kind of front-loaded a lot of ancient
and medieval philosophy into your class
and the way some people would teach this
class they'd be doing a bit of ancient
hardly any medieval a ton of modern
philosophy the reason that they would do
that is because a lot of interesting
things happen in the modern period this
guy an ad card that we're going to look
at for the next three class sessions
he's right in the center please consider
being one of the fathers of modern
philosophy and sort of you know life
that we live now we're not really the
modern in our what they call the
postmodern or late modern world
Rene Descartes is one of the people
who's responsible for a lot of many
people but he is one of the founding
fathers you might say so we're going to
look at a lot of material today because
of the way that the semester is going
have collapsed a lot of the cart into
three days normally we might take one
day each for each of the meditations but
we just don't have that time
so we're going to pass over stuff pretty
quickly and I'm going to point out a lot
of parallels to things that you have
seen or thought about movies in
particular actually but it's sort of up
to you to connect the dots these and
where I want to start actually the
fragment is biography or anything like
that I want to think about something all
of you had to experience many times in
your life
being tricked or fooled or deceived
right what are some examples of that
okay good so why what else didn't you go
on like haunted hay rides this Halloween
or anything like you're going to haunted
house not have you did anything like
that so what's going on with that I mean
you know going in there it's not me all
right oh yeah I mean when I took my
little daughter through the first time I
think she may have thought that there
were monsters in the haunted house
because she wanted to get out of there
right away but why don't we go there
we're going we're paying people to
deceive us right and better they deceive
us the more we pay them so you know
costumes how also you didn't see people
lie to you that's that's not much fun
yeah yeah okay magic there's like a
special name for that but I can't recall
it on here
there's sleight of hand and then there's
there's something more involved in that
as well
it will come to me so slightly and
tricks how else are you been through and
have you ever seen a mirage Creek like
you know you're driving along and you
see that it looks like water on the
highway but it's not really water
because it's some sort of strange thing
because the air and the refraction and
all that so there are visual
illusions oh yeah magic and illusionist
right let's specialize in him
where do you made mistakes where you
thought something is one way but it
turned out to be a different way I'll
tell you about one I did maybe this
little call things to mind have you ever
walked into a window you know they've
got those blast doors and then it'll be
like a window next to it and it's been
really recently cleaned it kinda looks
like a doorway because it's really wide
remember when I was probably 16 walked
right into one you know and actually
busted up my nose a little bit as I was
moving pretty fast
what else do we get mixed up about do we
get deceived about
or just being fooled where do we see
things that aren't there here things if
I were to call you on my phone and put
that phone up to your ear am I in here
here that nobody here actually thinks
there's like a little me inside the box
I hope right that all you go look out
your contacts list these are these are
all the people on there inside your
phone right now you don't think that
right there's something going on there
mmm your senses are telling you one
thing and what's telling you something
else because your senses are telling you
my friend my parent my so-and-so they're
right here what's telling you otherwise
you can fool a dog with that sort of
stuff can't you do tricks on
dogs and cats make them think that
somebody's there when they're not there
how come you can't be fooled that way
would it be image to have both a massive
brain compared to theirs of yours how do
you see through things
well me but it's see a different way are
there any are there any things where you
were fooled before now you're not fool
like when you're a kid you got mixed up
about things but now you don't why not
yeah well there's the holy Hannah glasse
and Easter Bunny
oh that's example yeah now and that you
know of course the leprechauns know if
they come for Saint Patrick's Day and
the Tooth Fairy and give me other things
like that Santa Claus yeah you know my
dad used to mess with the neighbor kids
he would tell them that he don't let the
dog out we had a ferocious dog so I'm
gonna let the dog out the dogs gave mr.
bunny the kids get very upset and they
were getting upset over nothing right
because there there isn't any Easter
Bunny who's the Easter Bunny hopefully
this video won't be seen by the kids
that's mom and dad or whoever so you
were fooled by that once but then later
on you you weren't have any of you ever
had any food sebaceans at any time
something went wrong upstairs can happen
if you're overtired when I used to work
these late night security jobs I'd be
walking along and you'd see your mind
wants to see order in things so you see
a blush and you think it's a deer and
you almost you know until you look at it
carefully you think there's actually a
deer there or you look down there's a
sticking thing at the stake you can
almost see it move there's other ways to
have loosen a shoes you know if you're
very sick you're taking certain kinds of
gloves there's wires crossed in your
brain
brain damage hallucinations those aren't
real right
there's an even more common way almost
every night most of us what's that
exactly how many of you drink all of
your dream there are some people who
don't or they don't remember their
dreams you've woken up from a dream it
was a good dream and you're mad because
whatever it was that you were doing
you're no longer able to do it you're
stuck in bed in your dorm room or you
know wherever know there's other dreams
you wake up from you're really happy the
dream is over
have any of you ever had a dream within
a dream like you wake up and you think
that what we're going to talk about
inception in a couple of minutes but
have any of you ever had a dream where
you have a dream and then you wake up
and you think that you're done because
now you get up you like they brush your
teeth or take a shower whatever you do
in the morning and then you go about
your day and then you find out that was
a dream too I never had that
it's kind of rare yeah isn't that
frustrating the worst yeah the worst
part is if you like go to work you put
in a full day and then you don't get
paid I'm in dream you know when I used
to work a lot I would have dreams like
that and it would it would frustrate me
so much so dreams are another way in
which we could fool
we're going to talk about some of these
movies like Inception it's been a fairly
recent the matrix you've all seen the
matrix effect we have probably the whole
trilogy how many of you seen Dark City
nobody's seen Dark City how about the
13th floor is going to do of any of ever
seen that or something else that we kind
of like that would be the game that was
in the 90s with Michael Douglas there's
other movies along these lines Inception
is probably the most recent movie of
that sort the Nilla sky would be the
Navy sea Vanilla Sky that would be sort
of like a Tom Cruise and also some bad
Cameron Diaz couple other stars
well all of this ties in with Rene
Descartes and all this ties in with
meditation one and two and all this ties
in at the beginning of modern philosophy
you might say what does all this have to
do with you know things we've been
looking at so far well I think about the
history of philosophy and think about
what we've been doing this class so far
not any given topic like does God exist
or not or what is the good or how should
society be organized was there only one
answer that you got during this but see
some heads changing you got multiple
answers right sometimes even in the same
book like remember Socrates and source
images whole markets and all these other
guys are arguing with each other about
you know whether it's this way to that
way so what do we see in the history of
philosophy if you pick a given topic can
you ask about it you ask questions about
it you'll get a range of different
philosophical answers remember
metaphysics but one Aristotle just laid
out this is what some people think is
that the cause is what other people is
what other people chelate about fifteen
different positions out that you guys
plug your way through so that's one part
now the other part is what philosophers
actually use what's their tool for
figuring all these things out but not
just going my feeling right they're
using the human mind what part of the
human mind what part of the human being
are they supposed to be using think back
to your Plato we have appetites then we
have the spirited part of the soul and
then was the other haider part you
remember
Plato thought it was what is most you
Epictetus thought that two sources are
rational is a adjective for it and
what's the down rationale you're just
changing the the order call that the
accent to the rational rationale
rationale comes from reason right yeah a
rationale is a type of reason and
philosophers are supposed to be using
reason and you know the thing that's
supposed to be so great about reason is
if we're all being rational we should
all more or less arrive at the same
point it shouldn't be affected by our
motions or our interests or desires or
things like that so on the one hand
philosophy you ask a philosophical
question you get about eight different
answers from philosophers on the other
hand shouldn't they all be on the same
page if they are really rational so
there's kind of a problem there isn't
there so if you look at the history of
philosophy if your dick hard looking
back and saying all right we've got all
these guys before me but they don't
agree on things now what could you do in
a case like what would you do get a
bunch of friends and they're all
jabbering at you they're all telling you
to do contradictory things how would you
deal with that haven't you ever been in
that situation correct you have a whole
bunch of friends and they're all giving
you different stories
how could you deal with something like
that
whether your options
okay so ignore all of them do what you
want to do maybe pick the one that
sounds the best here that's one of them
do it what else we're still bugging you
while you're doing that though what else
could you do maybe you you know you try
to sit down with them and say well let's
take a little bit of this a little bit
of this a little bit of this that's what
they call a collectivism you could also
just say all of you shut up I don't want
to hear any more out of all of you I'm
going to figure this out on my own
because clearly none of you can actually
arrive at the conclusions that would
convince anybody else that's what the
cart does he's saying a big shut up
to the history of philosophy he's
[Music]
in effect saying let's start over but
let's take everybody else out of the
room as a matter of fact you know in
those first two meditations it's just
him in the room visible cam and maybe
God or a demon or something like that
you know and a stove that he's in front
of a fireplace no other people telling
him what to do it's him on his own
that's what it means to meditate to go
off by yourself and to think about
something and so that's what he's doing
now
the reason I've got this picture up here
about a tree not very good tree but you
get the idea right here's the the roots
and here is the trunk and here as the
branches there's the leaves and all
that's um a metaphor that decart use to
describe what he wanted to do in
philosophy and you thought that
metaphysics you got to get the
metaphysics right you got to figure out
what actually exists and then you build
up rooms out of that and then from that
is going to come three things that will
revolutionize the world they will put
everything on a firm basis and fix
things
what is mechanics and if you think about
it your entire your entire environment
that you live in is the product of all
sorts of mechanical processes everything
you're wearing right now and once you
blow it by yourself was fabricated by
machines human run machines but machines
anyway yes that wasn't a round into
carts time that's a product of having
certain knowledge about how to make
things work the way they do your body
has been modified in countless ways I'm
sure all of you were inoculated against
diseases when your little babies you
don't remember it right maybe you do
I don't and if you weren't inoculated
against those probably some of you would
be dead by now you wouldn't exist any of
you who have anything like orthopedics
or uhit braces or you took medicine for
something and you'll have to do it now
or if you wear glasses or maybe wore
glasses at one time and now your eyes
are better or you wear contacts all of
that is part of mechanics and part of
medicine
those things change the world and get
cut cut how are you going to establish
that well those are essentially here's
of big things if you get your physical
you can make those things happen
and you'll do it by introducing the
scientific method in mathematics into
everything possible and then finally you
thought that even morals or ethics could
be made into something like a science he
never got around to that part Descartes
did a lot of experiments I did a lot of
you know dissecting animals and trying
to figure out how they worked and you
know looking at bodies as sort of like
mechanical processes and he actually did
go to the University and study some of
these things but what he's concerned
with here is metaphysics figuring out
what's ultimately real what can you put
a basis on what can you say is this way
or that way and you can be a hundred
percent certain number what's left out
of this is actually another field of
philosophy called distal mala G remember
what's epistemology about a lot of you
did pretty well
midterm exam when I asked you about this
what is it mr. Balaji you ones you
remember
so I feel like with right-wrong that's
up X yeah yeah stealing's knowledge how
do you know for it for example that I
know what I'm talking about how do you
know I'm not just making this crap up as
I go along
right coming in here and taking marys
dollars and just giving you some sort of
spiel about dick hard you know next week
it's going to be calm but you know we'll
do Paragard how do you know that that's
an epistemological question isn't it how
would you figure out whether I know what
I'm talking about I hope I hope that you
do thinks that if I'm talking about and
that you feel relatively secure in that
but I hope that you actually have good
reason to believe that I know what I'm
talking about do you
what's your basis see asking the answer
asking an epistemological question you
have any group the school wanted higher
do you remember you don't know about
that
I know I've known places where people
lied about their degrees got hired and
then I got fired afterwards when people
found out usually cuz students complain
how do those students know that this
professor didn't know what they were
talking about well they would read the
book and they'd say this doesn't sound
even remotely like take heart as I've
read dick heart I don't think this
person actually knows what they're doing
then they start digging into it but able
to judge whether somebody else knows
something you have to have some sort of
basis for that
remember back woods goes all the way
back to Socrates in wanting to know
who's wise and who's whose ignorance and
then how to tell whether they're wiser
or ignorant it's the same thing for your
old knowledge how do you know what you
know well let's take a couple things
what do you think that you know
I'm not trying to be flip here I'm not
I'm not trying to be you know challenge
you or make you put you down or anything
like that really what are some things
that you do now because you actually do
know a ton of stuff you just don't
realize that all you don't address
yourselves the fact somebody would be in
here their pants is beyond their head
like a jesters hat or you know socks on
their ears or something like that what
are some more important things that you
know that got you here interest
right now like how to address that's
pretty important stuff you know a lot of
people in the world don't know how to do
that and throughout history didn't know
how to do that well I don't know how to
write you know how to write you guys you
guys have these facilities that you
developed as children and then you've
kept on using and you don't realize how
smart you are compared to everybody else
throughout history you know the level of
education that you guys have at this
point is higher than most people
throughout history
so yeah mathematics right and what else
dressing yourself that's important yeah
yeah that's very odd that's a
generational thing right
they have a special cellphone for old
people called the jitterbug many various
events it's got really big buttons it
doesn't have a lot of features because
they don't want to be over a little bit
but you can give somebody your age
unless they you know like deliberately
don't want to deal with technology you
can throw them a cell phone and they can
figure out what to do with it fairly
quickly and that's a very complex set of
of operations that you guys take for
granted all you drive I'm guessing right
but you know well those of you who do
drive you learn something pretty
complicated you know you're managing a
ton of metal hurtling around at speeds
that people throughout history could
only dream up in a whole herd of other
people all doing the same and you don't
crash it that's pretty good that's
actually some some knowledge there what
do you know about yourself more personal
touch a knowledge
you all know your own histories right
none of you woke up this morning like in
a science fiction thing not knowing
exactly who you are finding a briefcase
next to your bed couple documents in it
got a piece together your past out of
that that's not not the case for you
right hopefully that or have any of you
ever seen that will give a mental no but
that's a good movie I mean if I may show
that later philosophy classes this guy
have no capacity to form long term
memories after a certain point so he has
to tattoo all the sort of nation on
himself so that when he wakes up he
doesn't freak out so he knows you know
some rudiments of who he is and what he
what he's up to
because somebody killed his wife he's
trying to track down the killer you're
having cases like that what do you know
about yourself holder you guys 18 in
some are 19 you know what else are you
hand up or People's Republic of China or
gray gets robbed right there are new
foreign exchange students this is
trivial stuff right but this is actually
things that you think you know about
yourself how do you know that you're
right
how do you know for example this isn't
just one big dream you're not some poor
kid in Ethiopia who got high on uncut we
had is hallucinating and thinks that you
know you're so-and-so in America they're
saying this is such a great dream I hope
it never ends you know how do you know
that's an epistemological question
that's the sort of thing that the card
is is introducing us to so let's
actually look
what Descartes says about this he begins
by saying I decided this is he was about
thirty years old when he was talking
about doing this that once and for all
in my life I should get rid of all my
former opinions and then try to build
everything back up and people do this
pretty rarely in their lives most people
just keep going on with you know fairly
secure the knowledge that they have the
Carters try to throw everything away and
then rebuild everything the only time
that you see people doing this
deliberately unless they're philosophers
tends to be if there's some sort of
crisis in their life they're their whole
world is broken apartment now they have
to piece it back together Descartes is
doing this deliberately because he wants
to acquire knowledge he wants to remake
philosophy he wants to be the
philosopher he wants to get rid of all
the past and begin anew and I think it's
probably something you can relate to
some of you at least at this point and
later on in your life you'll be able to
relate to that as well because there
come times where you eventually want to
say something like what I said earlier
all of you shut up I don't want to hear
any more of this stuff I want to start
again on my own so I actually know what
I'm doing here
that's what dick harp is trying to do so
what does he start with he starts with
the things that I asked you about you
know have you ever been deceived in your
life sure Descartes was too sometimes
she dreams that he's sitting sitting in
front of the fire but he's not actually
is in his bed and you know if you look
at around or you look at a square tower
from a distance it looks round if you
put a stick in the water what happens to
it does it Bend
looks back though right so there's all
different ways in which we can be
deceived and you know not only yeah
physical things sometimes people lie to
us sometimes people put on shows and
delude us we actually as Americans in
the late you know modern era we
deliberately fool ourselves
portion of the day I mean right now
you're half of you are on computers and
you're looking at
computer-generated images that have
become extremely sophisticated you know
you look at some screens and they look
like they're actually wood or paper or
all that sort of stuff that's actually
deception though isn't it and when
you're watching a show on TV what shows
are what shows you know right off the
bat are fake sitcoms you know when when
Charlie Sheen took his crazy nosedive
into lou.neil and and he got canned from
Two and a Half Men yeah they killed his
character I think right but does that
mean Charlie Sheen is actually dead he's
out there still he doing what he does
whatever that is and they brought in
somebody else to replace him re actors
really like the characters they portray
so my actors seem to be really nice and
they're characters and they're total
jerks all there is you know I always
playing bad guys but they're actually
quite nice people so those are fake what
else is fake
in your experience what about reality
shows I mean they're the parts of them
you have to be real right there's these
actual people some of them are the real
parts are actually kind of dissipating
like any of you watching hoarders show
and then you see you know what happens
with those people or or I don't like to
watch it but I know people like to watch
Hell's Kitchen with Gordon Ramsay and
that he's got two shows is that the one
where he goes in and restaurants are
screwed up and they tries to get him to
fix the restaurant
no its Kitchen Nightmares and there's
real stuff there there's a real grill
there your film again people have actual
breakdowns and fights if the meat is
rotten you can actually see it on that
show but there's also something kind of
think about it - doesn't there
I mean first off you're not there in
that kitchen in New Orleans or you know
San Antonio or anything like that you're
up here in the Hudson Valley at Marist
or whoever is watching this is wherever
they are in the world they're not in our
classroom are they we're creating a
deception in a way right now by filming
this and we take this for granted now I
did Kurt's time they didn't have all
that technology to do that we're a bit
more sophisticated about that but it
raises certain problems how do you know
that the information that you're getting
is actually true the information that
you're relying on can you ever be 100%
sure let's start with winning campus
he starts with physical things can you
be sure right now that you're not at a
drink sometimes when when people teach
Descartes she'll be like one student in
the class who gets freaked out and the
class now they can't tell whether
they're in a dream or not that's like
their whole world is falling apart and
it really upsets them hopefully none of
you are though that student right but
you get the idea I can't could you
actually you know could you prove that
this isn't a dream could I just be a
figment of your imagination right now
yeah that's what's possible how would
you know
are there any marks and he tells that
you can use to figure out that this this
isn't a dream I mean you can like poke
me get a pad and poke me but I don't
know I have dreams where I'm fighting
people that seems pretty real to me
thankfully not so much anymore
terrible news we have to fight these
people and no matter what you did they
they just keep coming at you break their
arms and legs keep coming
try to get you when I first started
teaching everything everybody I think
has a dream where you show up in your
underpants that dream no that's a bad
dream but when I first started teaching
the dream that I would have was I would
be going into this huge lecture hall and
I would have you know like four
different classes that I'd be teaching
at the time I'd go into this giant
lecture hall like 200 students or so and
they'd all be kind of watching as I come
in and I would get to the podium and I
would realize I have no idea what class
this is or where we are in the semester
and you know you don't want to ask
anybody because then they'd lose
confidence in you as a teacher right
what would you do if your
we asked you what class is this what do
you think so you know what I do in that
dreamer I did is I just kind of haven't
ha around and say really general things
kind of ask you know Socratic questions
and try to get a sense of what class
this could possibly be because I used to
teach like you know whole range of
classes I actually end up teaching
something like 19 different classes when
I was teaching in that prison
and students don't help me out at all
can I go for the entire hour not knowing
what we're actually talking about just
sweating you know and I can that I can
always feel like I'm just like one step
away from the whole thing falling down
and everything you know going to ruin
that was pretty real and I'd wake up
from it and I would be I'd be so
relieved
how can you tell that you're not in a
dream
let's let's put that one off for a
moment wondered what would the
hallucination or what was the thing be
about all of this stuff is about what we
perceive through our senses right if I
think that I've been a massive classroom
with 200 students who won't give me you
know the title of the class or anything
like that
I'm visually hallucinating I'm
auditorially hallucinating there may be
multiple factorial gustatory
tactile hallucinations spatial news
illuminations you know I move around and
I you know I'm not actually moving in
bed but I think that my body actually is
right if this is actually some sort of
hallucination right now or a dream that
somebody is having or a
computer-generated thing like the matrix
then we're all stuck in if I move over
here
you think I'm actually moving in space
right you think that you're sitting in a
desk in reality you might be laying in
bed you might have just been hit by a
car and things are going haywire in your
brain you might be stuck like involve
all seeing the matrix you've all seen
those things that the human beings were
stuck in with all the tubes on UM's so
they can act like batteries that could
be the case if that's really the case
then your senses are deceiving so you
really shouldn't put a lot of credence
in what your sense is telling you until
you figure out how to tell what's true
and what's false so we can doubt our
senses is there anything else you get
down when you're dreaming it's two plus
two still equal to four
the laws of mathematics and logic still
hold is a triangle still have to have
three three sides yeah I mean whoever
you want to be here I suppose maybe it's
edible to make it up the triangle
smaller size yeah are you then then
you've actually got square but now let's
say let's say we brought it this is
where we - what we call hyperbolic down
this is a term that's worth knowing when
it comes to Descartes what is hyperbole
little bitty know that that term offhand
yeah very good it's so if I say it's a
little bit warm in here right now if I
say oh my god it's so hot in here I'm
sweating bullets or something like that
I'm being hyperbolic right or if I say
you're the worst class of students I've
ever had or you're the best class of
students I've ever had I'm probably
being hyperbolic right big hyperbolic is
going extra going-over doing more than
you need to do to try to stress a point
now there's something that you should
doubt let your heart says your senses it
would be kind of strange to doubt
whether you actually have a body though
wouldn't it that's hyperbolic but why is
he doubting things like that well he
wants to again wipe away everything so
that we can build on absolutely clear
distinct undisputable foundations and if
you want even further with this we can
doubt the let's call them laws
mathematics
so if a is equal to B B is equal to C a
is equal to b and b is equal to c a is
equal to c right that's the what do they
call it the transitive yeah that's a
transitive property isn't it you know
that's major i it's been a long time
since I've done any logic or may ask
along those lines so that's basically a
lot logic right could that be false
could it be that that God designed
things in such a way that every time
that like to card set every time that I
add two and two is actually equal to
five but I go wrong and I think that
it's four is that possible it's possible
isn't it could you imagine a universe in
which that's the case in which were
systematically deluded over and over
again about things and think about the
physical world that you know about this
seems pretty solid even this seems
pretty solid my body solid what do you
know from physics class is this really
solid mostly space isn't it empty space
so the way in which we're thinking about
things the language were perceiving
things is not reflective of the
underlying reality of things this error
is slightly more space than this this
body is so maybe we could doubt these
maybe we could doubt everything maybe
like Descartes says maybe I have no body
maybe there's no exterior world maybe
all of these things are just sort of
thoughts put into my head
and they could be put into my head a
couple different ways he's got an
argument for God's existence which I'm
going to pass over in the first
meditation because we don't a lot of
time then then he brings up this idea
that evil genius or evil demons
translate in different ways Molly and
Jani is the French for it and he says it
quickly that there's some sort of let's
call it an evil demon right there's a
demon that deceives me with all this
stuff so what you're experiencing right
now your dick hard this is all false
these are all just ideas that have been
put into your head by an all-powerful
not good godlike creature will you be
fooled about just about everything wind
shear what couldn't you be
is there anything that you couldn't be
fooled about that you're 18 years old
wearing plaid pants that could be false
you might not have any legs or anything
you might have come into existence
yesterday your membranes could all be
false they could have been put into your
head maybe somebody's just out there
messing around with you like those
creatures in Dark City or in the matrix
where everything is actually
computer-generated and none of the life
that you've lived is really true you've
just been in a what would you call it
like a pocket a cell or something like
that your whole life you know sparking
up the machine or in Inception I even
actually see an inception what's what's
the what's the story there you're going
to dream right
Lucianne inception so what is the story
in the conception where is the deception
there it's a dream world right so it's
not it's not real can you die in it in
the dream world
no okay where where are the actual
people what's up on a plane wait here
see okay
I'll see that them I don't get robbed
seen many movies these days what
couldn't you be fooled about I mean this
guy was here might not actually be mr.
Davis
he might actually be miss Moriarty
maybe maybe all of their qualities got
somehow swapped and you know all her
memories got downloaded into him and all
of his memories got downloaded into her
and now they think that they're they're
different people they could be wrong
about the content what couldn't they be
wrong about this is where we get to the
famous code because they call it the
Cartesian coach ito
he hasn't probably at one time heard
Haruto ergo sum in history humanities
class or something like that
this means I think therefore I am
or I exist you can be deceived about
everything the one thing that you could
not be deceived about is the fact that
you better do exist
somebody can try to convince you that
you're not real right like if we're in
one big hallucination maybe if I'm kind
of a jerk I tell you I think you're all
just figments of my imagination you
don't have any real existence on your
own but you could say to me I think
therefore I am as soon as you say I
think you have to be existing who's
doing the thinking if you are deceived
by some evil genius you exist that's a
bear fat that can't be taken away that
can't be stripped away or student you
can't be swindled out of you might say
the carp doesn't actually say it quite
like this in the meditations but this is
good enough for where we are he says if
I'm received I have to exist and what I
am I that I'm not my body what could I
possibly be
let's think back to Plato what if Plato
said you're not your body right what are
you it's kind of similar to the
Christian traditional Christian notion
of it you're not just your body right
exactly you're you're a soul Descartes
doesn't use the language of the soul all
the time
he more often talks about mind so if
your body is not actually real if this
stuff that you're experiencing could be
doubted this could in fact be a dream or
a hallucination or whatever what do you
know it is real yes I think human being
is what Descartes calls a thinking
substance or a nine or a soul you have a
body
maybe we'll see as we go through the
other meditations whether you can you
have two grounds for saying that let's
just say for the time being you have a
body your body is not you your body is
just a bunch of meat that happens to be
inhabited by a mind which makes it do
all the things that it does all the
conscious things it doesn't make it
breathe that's purely mechanical that's
bought ematic as a matter of fact your
mind is not even your brain your brain
is physical
your mind is non-physical it's spiritual
a car let's say and this introduces us
already - what's often to call the
mind-body problem which is
oK you've got these two parts how
exactly do they fit together yeah well
since the brains part of your body isn't
your brain produces the fall well that's
that wouldn't really have thoughts about
the brain because you'd be dead
Descartes doesn't think so
Descartes is what we call duelist
so he thinks there's there's two kinds
of substance there's Minds and then
there's bodies and he has a kind of
weird way of explaining how it is that
you're going to actually interacts with
your brain that nobody accepts these
days he thought it was a pitiable gland
it gets kind of bounced around sore like
you know almost like a tonsil something
like that that's kind of silly but but
the general idea is that somehow this
non-physical thing makes things happen
in the brain so that the brain is not
just where everything's taking place
independent on its own the brain is sort
of like think of it like machinery right
now they didn't have the same
conceptions of the brain that that we do
now didn't know was full of electrical
impulses or neurons or they thought with
more in terms like Springs and wheels
you know very mechanical but they were
working with you know the best biology
and physics that they had time they
thought of nerves is almost being sort
of like strings that would pull and we
know now they're you know
condiments but the basic idea that we're
not reducible to our bodies that's the
important thing to take away from this
that we are more something disengaged
from our bodies the more our intellect
or our will or our imagination then we
are this meat and bones that were the
end sort of like Descartes says a pilot
in a ship the pilot you know the pilot
gets off the ship everyone and the ship
is just there for the pilot right the
ship is is not something that has
importance by itself it's kind of handy
to have if you want to get from point A
to point D let's think instead of
shipping a pilot think of you in a car
the car the driver does the car exists
for the driver or the driver exists for
the car cards is for the ride it doesn't
matter what car you have unless you know
you're really vain about course or
something like that right it doesn't
really matter what body you have what
matters is what's actually in your your
mind and so what does your mind do well
you talks about all these different
things all these different mental
operations he says I have a thing that
doubts your doubting is not something
you're doing bodily doubting is
something that your mind is
understanding again you know your brain
could maybe like mimic the structure of
what it was that you're understanding
some brain scientists think that you
know we have like you know this set of
neurons for coffee cup this set of
neurons for iPhone and this set of
neurons
ball cap and you know that's the way it
works I don't know if that's actually
the case maybe more complicated but
that's just sort of like a big storage
device the actual understanding that's
done by your mind is not done through
your body it's done the independent of
your body yeah do you agree with this oh
it's a good question do I agree because
like if you think about it if certain
parts of the brain are damaged then you
lose certain functions of the body
yeah so you have to think that the brain
which is part of the body has to do
something with it yeah do I personally
agree with that which I usually tend not
to bring up because I'm just trying to
you guys to understand it first I'm not
a Cartesian duelist I'm a person who
believes that we do have bodies or you
know in some ways we are bodies and I do
believe that we have souls that were not
reducible to our body but I believe that
the body of the source are fused
together sort of more Aristotelian
Aristotle said that the soul is the form
of the body it's that which gives the
body animation and its meaning and that
sort of thing there are some problems
with that view too
this is this kind of comedian do if you
really don't care about bodies much or
you want to see bodies is just purely
mechanical and that's pretty good if you
like you know into certain types of
Medicine you know you see the body is
just a bunch of mechanical processes
that that's helpful sometimes what else
do we do we will things that as we say
I'm going to do this I'm not going to do
this like right now I'm willing to walk
across the room I'm unwilling to leave
the room right now because you know
class isn't done
I affirm things I deny them again all
this is done through the mind it's not
done through the body so you know that
evil genius that evil demon looks like
the scope of what it actually has
control over is smaller than we thought
it can fool us about sense perception
maybe it can even fool us about you know
whether two plus two equals four but it
can't fool us about all this other stuff
provided we use our minds right now
doesn't it hard to actually think that
there is you know some sort of evil
demon fooling us or we're just in a
dream he doesn't actually think that
well let's you know as class as we
finish up class let's think about some
movies where that's the case let's think
about the matrix because I've actually
seen that one what's going on in the
matrix the first one not not all the
other sequels and all that because I
think it's really complicated you guys
gave me do remember yeah I'm right next
we're sunglasses a lot pretty fit it's
got a dead-end job what happens to
anyone remember how the how it starts if
the red pill on the blue pill what's
going on yeah yeah
like going down the rabbit hole if you
called it so red pill is go back to
reality just as the way it seems keep on
going on with the illusion blue pill
takes you down the rabbit hole what's at
the end of the rabbit hole don't know
the truth about things and the truth
about things is who's actually in charge
not the human beings anymore but the
Sentinels are a type of what a type of
program or machine and the machines are
in charge of the world right they've
gone wild you know we should have
created such smart machines and we have
this sort of fantasy of creating
creatures that destroy us then what do
they turn human beings yeah we generate
electrical charge and we generate
electrical charge better when we're just
laying there vegetating or when one when
we're irritated or thinking that we're
doing things when we're being flooded
with sense-data and we think that we're
actually in an office working 9:00 to
5:00 getting off going out to the bar
meeting somebody taking them back home
kicking them out later pick whatever you
want right all this drama generates
better electricity and that's not much
of a way to live is it and you I think
all of you remember that big scene where
you just see like acre after acre human
beings
yes genomic view do you remember your
feeling when you saw that probably felt
a little repulsed at this thought of all
these people just laying their
vegetables and that's being deceived
constantly there's that gross scene
where they they get them out they pull
all the hoses off of them and he's got
holes in his back and he's clocking off
all this stuff that they have them
breathe while they're in the things and
it's kind of gross and now what where is
he he's in the real world he's no longer
just in the matrix in the imaginary
world he's no longer being deceived by
the evil genius this doesn't map exactly
because then you know who tries to kill
him all the time he's what they call
those the agents very good yeah yeah
these agents of their programs so I
guess they're still kind of in the
matrix but kind of not they they tapped
into it they can also be killed in real
life I don't think about all the things
that they do with them you know they
they download into his imaginary body
all these comfortable moves that now you
can do you know like dodging bullets you
know they're flattened past him and all
this kicking and punching and all that
sort of stuff they can't really modify
what his mind is because his mind is
independent of his his bodily existence
is there something sort of like that an
inception some sort of who makes them
with the imaginary world in Inception
again who's who's seen the movie so who
made the imaginary or is there no
explanation
machines again okay so what you might
think it up and then I'm in the world
that you thought up that's so that's a
different take you would be like the
evil genius Maggie's right there's
another movie that is kind of in some
ways posing the same kind of issues I
don't know if you've seen at the Blade
Runner of any of yours in the Blade
Runner you have these fake human beings
to call them replicants and they're very
similar to human beings except of course
they're stronger faster in some ways
smarter than growing in laboratories and
in order to try to keep them from going
crazy they give them false memories and
if you watch the movie carefully there's
one replicant in it that of course the
main character falls in love with
because it always has to happen and she
saves his life and then she realizes
that she's actually she doesn't know at
the start that she's a replicant that
all her memories are fake her entire
past is a fiction
she's only several years old and then
she finds it out that's kind of
devastating is to find out that you have
been deceived that you've been
systematically lied to it's like getting
kicked in the guts ontologically
existential and then there's actually
some hints in the book that it's based
on that the main character himself might
actually be around and when these things
are done really really well
they suggest to you that maybe it's a
little science fiction maybe this could
in fact be the way things are and
Descartes in a way prefigures all of
this Descartes thinking these problems
out four hundred years before they hit
the big screen because it's the same
basic problem
how do you know things about yourself
what can you actually be tidally is
about through your bond what about its
physical looking at you right now I can
see you here you say something I could
you know go up to you if I think you're
ghost and you know poke you your solid
back away or you smack me don't do that
there's any reaction but how do I know
you're not actually just a robot of some
sort
how do you know I'm not at this point in
two cards meditations we don't we don't
actually know the the truth of things as
they are in themselves he has this
example of the piece of wax you're
reading through meditation to what
happens to it it's got certain qualities
right and you pick up the piece of wax
it's got a certain shape you can smell
it it smells like the honey from the
comb what happens to it when you need it
what happens to the hardness of the wax
it melts things that are melted and
we're soft right that smell of the
honeycomb it goes away before you could
tap it and it made a sound what happens
you're tapping something that's liquid I
guess that makes it sound a little bit
right does it look the same
what's still the same that what is that
piece of Wax
it's not those properties it's not those
things that we detect it through the
senses it's actually when you understand
it with your mind to be and really when
you understand it to be at some sort of
extended substance that it has or at
least you thought had certain
characteristics if you're a chemist
you'd probably get the chemical formula
relaxed which I don't know maybe some of
you do it's been a long time since I've
been in chemistry class well that's the
way the external world is for us we can
know things about our own selves and
about our minds much more clearly than
we can about anything outside of it so
how are we going to get a world that we
could believe in that's what we're going
to leave off because he doesn't he
doesn't resolve that in that tation tune
he's going to resolve that with what
we're going to look at in meditation 3
and meditation 4 and we're going to do
kind of what looks like a detour real
and all this proof about God's existence
and all that think about to yourself why
is he bothering talking about God when
what we're really interested in is an
external world that's where I'm going to
leave you for it for this class and
we'll pick up again with this